need motivation watts top 10 with
elimination hey it's Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
add something so get ready to have no
regrets follow your heart and learn how
to build a great business like Jeff
Bezos in my take on his top 50 rules her
success to give you the belief that you
need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have no regrets I decided to do this
I I first talked to my my wife who is
sitting here in the audience and she had
married a you know relatively stable to
goofy but still relatively stable a
person working at a Wall Street firm I
worked at a quantitative hedge fund and
this was a hard decision and I was
looking for the right framework in which
to make that kind of important decision
and and and and and the right framework
I found is a regret minimization
framework and so that's just a nerdy way
of saying that you want to project
yourself to age 80 and then think back
over your life and and if you're if
you're if you're 81 or the thew want to
minimize the number of regrets you have
throughout that period of time I think
this is something a lot of people do
maybe subconsciously they probably very
few people probably name it regret
minimization framework because most
people are healthier than that but but
it was a very clear way for me to think
about making that kind of life decision
and the in the way it helped was I
thought okay if I go do this thing and
participate in this thing called the
internet that I genuinely believe is
gonna be a big deal and if I fail am I
gonna regret having tried and failed and
I knew the answer that was no but I also
knew that if I didn't try that I would
always regret that I would always wonder
and it would haunt me
and until that you know mythical day
which I actually hope will come rule
number two
follow your heart not your head many
many kids and many grown-ups do figure
out over time what their passions are
and sometimes we let our I don't think
it's that hard I think what happens
though sometimes is that we let our
intellectual selves overrule those
passions
and so that's what needs to be guarded
against rule number three invest more in
the product than in marketing I'm gonna
put the vast majority of my energy
attention and dollars into building a
great product or service and put a
smaller amount into shouting about it
marketing it because I know if I build a
great product or service my customers
will tell each other you have to mix in
some patience with that rule number four
pick a good name almost seven years ago
now I started this most incredible
journey called amazon.com actually at
that time it wasn't even called
amazon.com it was called Cadabra Inc as
an abracadabra that was the original
name of the company and I had phoned a
lawyer on the way to Seattle from a cell
phone and he said well what do you to
incorporate the company he says what do
you want the company to be called and I
said dad bruh he said cadaver and I knew
that was a bad name we changed it a few
months later also if you want to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
it's free the link to join is in the
description below the stress primarily
comes from not taking action if you
absolutely can't tolerate critics that
don't do anything new or interesting if
everything has to work in two to three
years then that limits what you can do
rule number five stain for something
what we have always wanted to do is
raise the standard for what it means to
be customer centric to such a degree
that other organizations whether they be
other companies or whether they be
hospitals or government agencies
whatever the organization is they should
look at Amazon as a role model and say
how can we be
as customer-centric as Amazon even
competitors I imagine right
hopefully competitors as well but if we
could make you know if that could be our
legacy that we kind of raised the
general idea of what it means to be
customer centric that would be a huge
accomplishment it would be accomplishing
a mission that's much bigger than
ourselves rule number six focus on the
customer we know customers like low
prices we know customers like big
selection and we know that customers
like fast delivery and those things are
going to be true ten years from now
they're gonna be true twenty years from
now so we can count on those things and
we can put energy into them we know
customers like their products fast and
so we work on things that we know
customers like what has worked at Amazon
is focusing on the customer being very
cutting the customer first which is easy
to say but difficult to do if you really
are customer centric it's like being the
host of a party you're holding the party
for your guests
sometimes the host the party is holding
the party for the host of the party and
that's that leads to a different kind of
party rule number seven focus on your
passion my advice would be the same for
any kind of entrepreneur and that is
make sure that you are focused on
something you're passionate about so if
you look at the early internet companies
they were started and focused on doing
something that they thought was very
interesting long before the internet was
fashionable in anyway you know I I you
know we are currently an underdog once
again we've been in business for six
years and there was exactly one year
where we were not the underdog and that
was 1999 I like the the underdog years
because it makes you know I liked it
when all the people we hired their
parents told them they were crazy like
that was the that was kind of the good
era fortunately it's back in 1999 all
the parents were like you know given
their brothers and sisters high fives
you know my son is working at Amazon
komm so that's a very you can't follow
the fashion when you're trying to do a
startup company or I think really
anything in life but you have to as an
entrepreneur if you're gonna if you're
gonna build a company pick something you
think is interesting that has the
intersection of genuinely creating real
customer value and then just stay right
there and let the weight of catch you
rule number eight build a culture so you
can hold a ballet and that can be
successful and you can hold a rock
concert and that can be successful just
don't hold a ballet and advertise it as
a rock concert and so you need to be
clear with all of your stakeholders with
you know are you holding a ballet or are
you holding a rock concert and then
people get to self-select in you know we
hire people who are who are really
motivated by building new customer
experiences they like to pioneer they
like the rate of change they they wake
up in the shower motivated by thinking
about customers and occasionally if
somebody joins Amazon who their primary
motivation comes from being thinking
about competition or competitors those
people can find Amazon a little Dolph
you know so and again it's not about
right or wrong it's just that different
people are motivated by different things
and what happens with corporate cultures
is that over time that you people
collect themselves and you know in a way
where they like that culture and then it
becomes self-sustaining rule number nine
sell premium products at non premium
prices one of the things you've done so
well at Amazon is you've undercut all of
your rivals by keeping the prices low
does that same strategy apply to tablets
yes our approach is premium products at
non premium prices so we saw the
hardware at break-even so we don't try
to make any money when we saw this
hardware and we hope to make money when
people use the devices not when they buy
the devices and so that's a very
different approach from most companies
most companies are building quite a bit
of profit into the sale of these devices
rule number ten take
risk whatever it is that you want to do
you there's gonna be risk in your life
and risk is a necessary component of
progress you can make any pioneering
movements in the world of any kind
whether they be the geographical
physical exploration that I've just been
talking about whether it be you know a
more cerebral exploration of a
scientific field or I bet you could ask
that question of every speaker here and
I bet that every speaker here has taken
substantial risks whether it be
intellectual or otherwise to achieve
what they're you know what they've done
rule number 11 take bold bets my job one
of my jobs as the leader of Amazon is to
encourage people to be bold and people
love to focus on things that aren't yet
working and that's good it's human
nature that kind of divine discontent
can be very helpful but you really you
know it's incredibly hard to get people
to take bold bets and you need to
encourage that and if you're gonna take
bold bets they're gonna be experiments
and if their experiments you don't know
ahead of time go they're gonna work
experiments are by their very nature
prone to failure but big success is a
few big successes compensate for dozens
and dozens of things that didn't work so
you know bold bets AWS Kindle Amazon
Prime our 3rd party seller business all
of those things are examples of bold
bets that that did work and they pay for
a lot of experiments I've made billions
of dollars of failures at Amazon com
literally billions of dollars of
failures and you know you might remember
pets.com or cosmo or you know give
myself a root canal with no anesthesia
very easily none of those things are fun
but but they also they don't matter what
really matters is companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace failure they eventually
get in the
desperate position where they only thing
they can do is make a kind of Hail Mary
bet at the very end of their corporate
existence where as companies that are
you know making bets all along even you
know big bets but not bet the company
bets I don't I don't believe in bet the
company bets that's when you're
desperate that's that's the last thing
you can do rule number 12 step
ferociously we know from our past
experiences that big things start small
you know the biggest oak starts from an
acorn and you've got to recognize you
you've got to be willing to let that
acorn grow into a little sapling and
then finally into a small tree and maybe
one day it'll be a big business on its
own in fact that's one of the mottos for
one of your initiatives and forgive my
pronunciation of the Latin but Greta
team for octa what does that mean to you
well it means step by step ferociously
and it's the motto for Blue Origin and
basically you can't skip steps you have
to put one foot in front of the other
things take time you there are no
shortcuts and but but you want to do
those steps with you know passion and
ferocity rule number 13 earn a good
reputation I think prior most important
piece of intellectual property is our
brand name and I think people and and I
think this is very important for anybody
who's gonna start a company or market an
invention to understand is that brands
for companies are like reputations for
people and reputations are hard-earned
and easily lost so the most important
intellectual property that a company can
have is for us it's that it's it's it's
Amazon it's that name but what it stands
for we've worked very hard to earn trust
you can't ask for trust you just have to
do it the hard way one step at a time
you make a promise and then fulfill the
promise you say we'll deliver this to
you you know tomorrow and then you
actually deliver it tomorrow
and if you do that over and over again
then ultimately you can instill your
company's name with a reputation and
that's I think you know sometimes people
talk about brands in this very amorphous
way but for me I like to think of it as
a person and what is the reputation that
that person has and how have they earned
that reputation number fourteen take
action I think stress you can be one of
the things that's very important to note
about stress is the stress primarily
comes from not taking action over
something that you can have some control
over so if I find that some particular
thing is causing me to have stress
that's a a warning flag for me what it
means is there's something that I
haven't completely identified perhaps in
my conscious mind that is bothering me
and I haven't yet taken any action on I
find as soon as I identify it and make
the first phone call or send off the
first email message or whatever it is
that we're gonna do to start to address
that situation even if it's not solved
the mere fact that we're addressing it
dramatically reduces any stress that
might come from it so stress comes from
ignoring things that you shouldn't be
ignoring I think in large part so stress
doesn't come people get stress wrong all
the time my opinion stress doesn't come
from hard work for example you know you
can be working incredibly hard and
loving it and likewise you can be out of
work and incredibly stressed over that
so and likewise if you kind of use the
you know use that as an analogy for what
I was just talking about if you're out
of work but you're going through you
know a disciplined approach of you know
series of job interviews and so on and
working to remedy that situation you're
going to be a lot less stressed than if
you're just worrying about it and doing
nothing rule number fifteen find work
life harmony if you're giving great
customer experience there's the only way
to do that is with happy people you
can't do it with a set of miserable
people you know watching the clock all
day so does that include work-life
balance and all those things yes but I
would I use I teach three leadership
classes a year at Amazon I'm a part of
it they're bigger classes but I come in
and teach a session and I always talk
about work-life balance except I like to
use the phrase work life harmony rather
than balance because to me balance
implies a strict trade
whereas I find that when I am happy at
work I come home more energized I'm a
better husband better dad and when I'm
happy at home I come in and a better
boss and better colleague and so that
that it's not you could be out of work
and we have terrible work-life balance
you know even though you've got all the
time in the world right you could just
feel like oh my god you know I'm
miserable and you would be draining
energy and so you have to find that
harmony it's a much better word and I
think for most people it's about meaning
people want to know that they're doing
something interesting and useful and for
us you know because of the challenges
that we have chosen for ourselves we get
to work in the future and it's super fun
to work in the future for the right kind
of person
rule number 16 execute your idea it's
easy to have ideas it's very hard to
turn an idea into a successful product
there are a lot of steps in between it
takes persistence relentlessness so I
always tell people who are you know who
think they want to be entrepreneurs it's
you need a combination of stubborn
relentlessness and flexibility and you
have to know when to bewitch and
basically you need to be stubborn on
your vision because otherwise it'll be
too easy to give up but you need to be
very flexible on the details because as
you go along pursuing your vision you
find that some of your preconceptions
were wrong and you're gonna need to be
able to change those things so I think
taking an idea successfully all the way
to the market and turning it into a real
product that people care about and that
really improves people's lives
it's a lot of hard work me number
seventeen have role models I had some
family role models and I had some other
people you know some sort of historical
role models that I looked at too so
certainly my my grandfather was a
serious role model for me I just said
fit so much time right you learn
different things from grandparents and
you learn from parents it's a it's a
great I would encourage anybody to try
to spend time not only with their
parents but with their grandparents and
but I and I also had I to people I
always would read about and we're Thomas
Edison and Walt Disney those were sort
of my - you know biographical heroes I
always been interested in in inventors
and invention and Edison of course just
you know for for a little kid is the and
probably for adults too I still feel
this way at least is that not only the
symbol of that but the actual fact of
that they just incredible inventor and
and I've always felt that there's a
certain kind of important pioneering
that goes on from an inventor like
Thomas Edison and then Disney was a
different sort of thing he also you know
a real pioneer and an inventor and doing
new things but it seemed to me that he
had this incredible capability to create
a vision that he could get a large
number of people to share because the
the things that Disney invented like
Disneyland you know the theme parks are
so and they were such big visions that
no single individual unlike a lot of the
things that Edison worked on no single
individual could ever pull them off and
and Walt Disney really was able to get a
big team of people working in a
concerted direction rule number 18 do
what you love I don't really remember
the exact day or anything but when I was
in college is when I started to think
about wanting to be an entrepreneur
someday so it was I was not the kid with
the lemonade stand you know I didn't I
wasn't one of these kids who was always
trying to race but I always wanted to be
a scientist when I was little yeah but
I'd also always loved computers I like I
was lucky because at my age this is
unusual to have access to a mainframe
computer from my elementary school and I
was in fourth grade and quickly learned
that there was a pre-programmed Star
Trek game on that computer and then I
never did anything except play Star Trek
with the computer so I don't know how
formative that was certainly led it's
really helped my Star Trek knowledge
considerably and and but I've always
loved computers somewhere in college I
started watching some of the people who
are like setting up you know college
pizza delivery services and you know the
kind of the core entrepreneurs and
thinking you know this looks like a
really fun thing to do rule number 19 be
a team player I ain't some very rare
idea that can be done by a single
individual almost everything that is
going to change the world solve a
problem improve something these are
usually big efforts and they require you
know teams a team working together to
really get something important done and
that has been the story of amazon.com
every step along the way we've had a
team here that is is making this work I
mean I don't know even even at the
smallest scale you have to figure out
how to get help from your friends from
your family members from people that you
can hire in those early days I think
without that it would never work number
20 think long term do something you're
very passionate about and don't try to
chase what is kind of the hot passion of
the day I think we actually saw this I
think you see it all over the place in
many different context but I think we
saw it in the internet world quite a bit
where you know it's sort of peak of the
sort of internet you know mania and say
1999 you found people who were you know
very passion or something they kind of
left that job and decided I'm gonna you
know do
something in the internet because it's
you know it was almost like the you know
the 18-49 Gold Rush in a way I mean you
find that people if you go back and
study the history of the 18-49 Gold Rush
you find that you know at that time
everybody who was in was within the
shouting distance of California was you
know they might have been a doctor but
they quit being a doctor and they
started panning for gold and that that
almost never works and even if it does
work you know according to some metric
financial success or whatever might be I
suspect it leaves you ultimately
unsatisfied so you really need to be
very clear with yourself and I think one
of the best ways to do that is this
notion of projecting yourself forward to
age 80 looking back on your life and
trying to make sure you've minimized the
number of regrets you have that works
for that works for career decisions it
works for family decisions you know do
want I have a 14 month old son and it's
very easy for me to if I think about
myself when I'm 80 I know I want to
watch that little guy grow up and so it
it's I don't want to be 80 and think
shoot you know I missed that whole thing
and I don't have the kind of
relationship with my son that I wished I
had and so on and so on so if you think
about that so I I guess another thing
that I would recommend to people is that
they always take a long term point of
view and I think this is something about
which there's a lot of controversy you
know there's a there's a you know
something a lot of people and I'm just
not one of them believe that you should
live for the now I think what you do is
you think about the the great expanse of
time ahead of you and try to make sure
that you're planning for that in a way
that's going to leave you ultimately
satisfied so this is just my this is the
way it works for me and I mean this is
everybody needs to find that for
themself so there are a lot of paths to
satisfaction and you need to find one
that works works for you
rule number 21 experiment more you
cannot invent and pioneer
if you cannot accept failure its you to
invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you know in advance that it's
going to work it is not an experiment
and so that's a very important thing you
know it's these they're inseparable
twins failure and invention it's so you
have to be willing to do that it's
embarrassing to fail you know it's
always embarrassing to fail but you have
to say no that's not how this works if I
said to you you have a 10% chance of a
with a particular decision a 10% chance
of a 100x return you should take that
bet every time but you're still going to
be wrong nine out of ten times and it's
gonna feel bad nine out of ten times and
in in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed they
it's very the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation you know everybody
knows that if you swing for the fences
you hit more home runs but you also
strike out more but with the baseball
that analogy doesn't go far enough
because with baseball no matter how well
you connect with the ball you can only
get four runs the success is capped at
four runs but in business every once in
a while you step up to the plate you hit
the ball so hard you get a thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff and you know one at
one at back and get you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments rule number 22
choose to do hard things
we all have adversity in our lives you I
I would I would I doubt if you really
you know if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to there's no
lack of adversity and the and by the way
that's good because it's what teaches us
how to get back up you fall down you get
back up it always happens and you know
you get certain gifts in life and you
want to take advantage of those
but you like it's my advice on adversity
and success would be to be proud not of
your gifts but of your hard work and
your choices so you know you may be the
kinds of gifts you get like you know you
might be really good at math it might be
really easy for you that's a kind of
gift but practicing that math and taking
it to the next step that could be very
challenging and hard and take a lot of
sweat that's a choice you can't really
be proud of your gifts because they were
given to you you can be grateful for
them and thankful for them and but your
choices you choose to work hard you
choose to do hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of
rule number 23 be an inventor if you
want to be an inventor of any kind
inventing a new you know a new service
offering for customers or a new product
or anything the being an inventor
requires because the world is so
complicated you have to be a domain
expert I mean in a way even if even if
you're not at the beginning you have to
learn learn learn learn learn enough so
to become a domain expert but the danger
is once you've become a domain expert
you can be trapped by that knowledge and
so inventors have this paradoxical
ability to have that you know ten
thousand hours of practice and be a real
domain expert and have that beginner's
mind have that that look at it freshly
even though they know so much about the
domain and that's the key to inventing
you have to have both and I think that
is intentional I think all of us have
that inside of us and we can all do it
but you have to be intentional about it
you have to say yeah I am going to
become an expert and I'm gonna keep my
beginner's mind rule number 24 go step
by step so your question is you know did
I kind of anticipate what would happen
over the last 22 years at Amazon and the
answer is god no
so you know Amazon started as a very
small company it was me and a few other
people I was driving all the packages to
the post office myself in my 1987 Chevy
Blazer and do it when I raised money for
Amazon I had to raise a million dollars
which I raised from 22 different
investors $50,000 each
they got 20% of the company for for the
million dollars and it was a 40 people
told me no so I did take 60 meetings to
get 20 yeses the first question was
always what's the internet and I had to
walk through that and this was 1994
early 95 and so did I anticipate you
know fast forward to today and and the
current version of it no it has been one
foot in front of the other and I think
that that is true for most businesses
where you kind of proceed adaptively its
step by step you figure it out you have
a success and then you kind of double
down on that success and you figure out
what what else you can do what customers
want
rule number 25 find your calling ever
since I was five years old that's when
Neil Armstrong stepped on to the surface
of the Moon I've been kind of passionate
about space rockets rocket engines space
travel I became a science fiction reader
and I've always known that I wanted to
you know do something having to do with
space and I've spent a lot of time
thinking about it for really almost my
whole life and that's one of the things
you guys will find that you have
passions and having a passion is a gift
I think we all have passions and you
don't get to choose them they pick you
but you have to be alert to them you
have to be looking for them and when you
find your passion it's a fantastic gift
for you because it gives you direction
it gives you purpose you could have a
job or you can have a career or you can
have a calling and the best thing is to
have a calling and if you find your
passion you'll have that and all your
work won't feel
work to you rule number 26 be nimble and
robust the thing for companies is you
need to be if you nibble and robust so
you need to be able to take a punch and
you also need to be quick and and and
and innovative and and doing new things
at a high speed that's that's the best
defense against the future and you have
to always be leaning in to the future if
you're if you're leaning away from the
future the future is gonna win every
time
never ever ever lean away from the
future rule number 27 be long-term
oriented I ask everybody to not think in
two to three-year timeframes but to
think in five to seven-year timeframes
to not think about when somebody says to
me congratulate Sam azan on a good
quarter which is a very common thing to
say you meet somebody there being nice
they looked at your financial results
for the quarter that good quarter I say
thank you but what I'm thinking to
myself is that quarter all that those
quarterly results were actually pretty
much fully baked about three years ago
and so like today I'm working on you
know a quarter that is going to happen
in 2020 not next quarter next quarter
for all practical purposes is done
already and it's probably been done for
a couple of years and so if you start to
think that way it changes how you spend
your time how you plan where you put
your energy and and your ability look
around corners gets better so many
things improve if you can take a long
term by the way it's not natural for
humans so it's a it's a discipline that
you have to build the the kind of you
know get rich slowly schemes are not big
sellers on infomercials you know it's
and so that's something that you have to
sort of steel yourself for discipline
and teach
over time rule number 28 choose a life
of adventure you can choose we all get
to choose our life stories and it's the
choices that define us not our gifts
everybody in this room has many gifts I
have many gifts you can never be proud
of your gifts because their gifts they
were given to you you might be you know
tall or you might be really good at math
or you might be extremely beautiful or
handsome or you know there are there are
many gifts and you can only be proudly
of your choices because those are the
things that you are that you're that you
are acting on and one of the most
important choices that each of us has
and you know this just as well as I do
is you can choose a life of ease and
comfort or you can choose a life of
service and adventure and when you're 80
which one of those things you think
you're going to be more proud of you're
gonna be more proud of having chosen a
life of service of adventure
rule number 29 find allies what
motivates me when times are rough you
know I find if I'm stressed about
something it's usually because I'm not
doing anything about it and so if I'm
stressed about something I'm trying to
trip why am i stressed I'm listening to
my body as a signal that I'm that
something is awry and then I find that
the stress goes away the second I take
the first step of you identify the
source of the stress why am i stressed
about this what's going on and then you
know talk to somebody about it find in
order to find allies you know I would
say that if you can find friends who are
interested in similar things or want to
help you solve a problem problem solving
is is inspiring for me all by itself I
have as long as I have allies there's
nothing more fun than getting in a room
with a group of
the inventors and saying look here's the
problem let's invent a solution to it
and as soon as you start doing that I
find that it turns from something that
might create stress into something that
creates fun
rule number 30 empower people on the
internet today you know two kids in
their dorm room can reinvent an industry
that's how how high it could because you
don't you the heavy lifting
infrastructures in place for that today
two kids their dorm room can't do
anything interesting in space you know
you could build a CubeSat there's not
that much interesting about cube chess
and the that may change but right now
there's just you need there are certain
laws of physics and certain things you
need size for and things need to be big
we need to be able to put big things in
space at low cost and so if I'm 80 years
old and I can say to myself that Blue
Origin did the heavy lifting you know
come are using my Amazon winnings to do
a new piece of heavy lifting
infrastructure which is low-cost access
to space vehicles have to be reusable
you can't throw them away throw away
space vehicles every time you're never
gonna lower the cost so we're trying to
lower the price of admission into space
so that thousands of entrepreneurs can
then do amazing surprising things nobody
and they tell you I've that much just
nobody in 95 predicted snapchat you know
it's like I can't predict for you what
amazing entrepreneurs brilliant amazing
entrepreneurs will do in space but I
know if I give them low-cost access to
space some brilliant you know 22 year
old is gonna figure it out it's one of
those things about what companies get
sustainable it's those that provide
platforms on upon which others can build
if you Amazon's power others empower
others to do things so AWS is like that
Kindle direct publishing is like that
our third-party selling businesses like
that fulfill up by Amazon is like that
every time you figure out some way of
providing tools and services that
empower other people to deploy their
creativity you're really onto something
rule number 31 focused on your customers
the secret sauce of Amazon with their
several principles at Amazon but the
number one thing that has made us
successful by far is
obsessive-compulsive focus on the
customer as opposed to obsession over
the competitor and I talk so often to
other CEOs and some of their CEOs and
also founders and entrepreneurs and I
can tell that even though they're
talking about customers they're really
focusing on competitors and it is a huge
advantage to any company if you can stay
focused on your customer instead of your
competitor
rule number 32 be resourceful I spent an
unusual amount of time with my
grandparents and especially with my
grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in South Texas and I would spend
my summers there from age 4 to 16 and
the when I was 4 they were taking me for
the summer to kind of give my parents a
break you know that's sort of because
they were so young and it was useful and
I was a handful I'm sure and anyway he
he he created the illusion for me when I
was 4 years old that I was helping him
on the ranch which of course could not
have been true but I believed it and and
then as by the time I was 16 of course I
was actually helping on the ranch I you
know I can fix prolapsed cattle I can
you know we did all of our own
veterinary work some of the cattle even
survived and we fixed windmills and laid
you know water pipelines and built
fences and barns and fixed the bulldozer
that you guys talked about and so one of
the things that's so interesting about
that lifestyle and about my grandfather
is he did everything himself you know he
didn't call of that if one of the annals
was sick he figured out what to do
himself and so what does it mean no
delegation being resourceful I think is
the you know that you can always you
can't if there's a problem there's a
solution
and of course issue is you mature and
and get into the business world and
anything you do on a team you very
quickly realize that it's not about just
your own resourcefulness it's about team
resourcefulness and how does that work
and rule number 33 love what you do I
have this great luxury I love my job I
tap dance into work even I get that I
just got back for an amazing vacation in
Norway I got to go dog sledding and go
to a wolf preserve and all this really
cool stuff but I couldn't wait to get
back to work because it's so fun and the
reason weather is this fun for me is I
get to work in the future so my job I
have very limited kind of day-to-day
operational needs that you know I've
constructed my job so that I don't have
to be pulled into the present I can stay
2 or 3 years in the future
rule number 34 start small everything
I've ever done has started small Amazon
started with a couple of people and Blue
Origin started with five people and the
budget at Blue Origin was very very
small now the budget at virgin has
approaches a billion dollars a year the
next year would be more than a billion
dollars in Amazon who literally was ten
people today it's half a million people
but you it's hard to remember for you
guys but for me it's like yesterday I
was driving the packages to the post
office myself and hoping one day we
could afford a forklift and so so for me
I've seen small things get big and it's
part of this day one mentality I like
treating things as if if they're small
you know Amazon even though it is a
large company I wanted to have the heart
and spirit of a small one rule number 35
learn how to deal with critics my
approach to criticism and what I teach
and preach inside Amazon is when you're
criticized first look in a mirror and
decide are your critics right if they're
right
change there are two kinds of critics
there are well-meaning critics who you
know they they're worried it's not going
to work but they do want it to work and
so it could be I could give you example
customer reviews and be one of those
when I first did customer reviews 20
years ago publishers were some book
publishers we're not happy about it
because some of them are negative and so
it was very controversial practice at
that time but we thought was right and
so we stuck to our guns and and and and
had a deep key on that and didn't didn't
didn't change but there's a second kind
of critic which is the self-interested
critic and they come in all shapes and
sizes you know they're so they can be
any kind of institution competitors of
course and so when you are doing some in
a new way and if customers embrace the
new way what's going to happen is
incumbents who are practicing the older
way are not going to like you and
they're gonna be self-interested critics
and so you do need as you're looking
yourself in the mirror to try and tease
those two things apart
rule number 36 be effective we try to
create teams that are no larger than can
be fed with two pizzas we call that the
two pizza team rule no powerpoints are
used inside of Amazon so every meeting
we have that when we hire a new
executive from the outside
this is the weirdest meeting culture you
will ever encounter and new executives
have a little bit of you know culture
shock and their first Amazon meeting
because what we do is somebody for the
meeting has prepared a six page memo a
narrative Lee structured memo that is
got you know real sentences and topic
sentences and verbs and now it's not
just bullet points and it lays out and
supposed to create the context for what
will then be a good discussion so and
then we read those memos silently in the
meeting so it's like a study hall and we
do that everybody sits around the table
and we read silently for usually about
half an hour however long it takes us to
read the document and then we discuss it
and it's so much better than the typical
PowerPoint presentation for so many
reasons I definitely recommend the memo
over the PowerPoint and the reason we
read them in the room by the way is
because just like you know high school
kids executives will Bluff their way
through the meeting as if they've read
the memo because we're busy and so
you've got to actually carve out the
time for the memo to get read and that's
what the first half hour of the meeting
is for and then everybody's actually
read the memo they're not just
pretending to have read rule number 37
follow your intuition I believe in the
power of wandering all of my best
decisions in business and in life have
been made with heart intuition guts you
know not not an analysis when you can
make a decision with analysis you should
do so but it turns out in life that your
most important decisions are always made
with instinct intuition taste heart rule
number 38 act on your great ideas I
picked books because there were more
items in the book category than any
other category and so you could build
Universal selection there were three
million in 1994 when I was pulling this
idea together the the the three million
different books active and in print in
any given time in the largest physical
bookstore has only had about a hundred
and fifty thousand different titles and
so I could see how you could make a
bookstore online with Universal
selection every book ever printed even
out of print ones was the original
vision for the company and so that's why
books when did you know that Amazon is
gonna be teased up going to be something
way bigger than just a bookstore well I
knew that the books strangely because I
was very prepared for this to take a
really long time I knew that the books
business was gonna be successful in the
first thirty days I was shocked at how
many books we sold we were ill-prepared
you know I had we had all the beds only
ten people in the company at that time
and most of them were software engineers
and so everybody including me and thus
offers were all like packing boxes we
didn't even have packing tables and down
we were on our hands and knees on a
concrete floor packing the boxes and
about you know 1:00 or 2:00 in the
morning I said to one of my software
engineering colleagues I said you know
Paul we this is killing my knees we need
to get knee pads and Paul looked at me
and he's like Jeff we need to get
packing tables I was like oh my god that
is such a good idea the next day I
bought packing tables and it doubled our
productivity and probably saved our
backs and our knees to rule number 39 be
a visionary my greatest I would have
such a good feeling if I could be an 80
year old guy and laying there thinking
about my life if I could say look there
is now a bunch of entrepreneurs in space
because I took my amazon lottery
winnings and built the heavy lifting
infrastructure that does take billions
of dollars in capex to lower the cost of
access to space that's how you get
millions of people living and working
and by the way we need that
for those of you who like to think about
the future at all you can do a simple
calculation you know we can argue about
you know what limited resources on earth
and so on and so on but here's the
calculation that you cannot argue with
which is you take current baseline
energy usage on earth compound it at
just a few percent a year for just a few
hundred years and you have to cover the
entire surface of the earth and solar
cells so you have to we're gonna have to
decide do we want a society of
pioneering invention expansion growth or
do we want a society of stasis and
personally I believe because the earth
is finite and if you want a society of
stasis I think it's good first of all I
don't personally believe the stasis is
even compatible with freedom so I think
for me that's a big problem
second of all it's gonna be dull stasis
is gonna be very dull you don't want to
live in the stasis world and so of
course we're gonna continue get more
efficient too we have been for hundreds
of years we've been getting more
productive more efficient
that's that trend is going to continue
but even so we're gonna want to use more
energy more energy per capita and also I
don't want to stabilize population I
would love for the vea trillion humans
in the source system with a trillion
humans we would have a thousand
Einsteins and a thousand Mozart's it'd
be an incredible symbols don't you want
that dynamism it'd be so much mercy my
this is for your great-great-great
grandchildren but what kind of world do
you want them to live in I want them to
live in that expansive world that is you
know learning more about the universe
and moving out throughout the source
system rule number 40 be willing to be
misunderstood if you're gonna do
anything new or innovative you have to
be willing to be misunderstood and if
you can't tolerate that and for God's
sake don't do anything new or innovative
every important thing we've done has
been misunderstood
often by well-meaning sincere critics
sometimes of course by self-interested
insincere critics rule number 41 act on
your ideas I came across the fact so
this is 1994 nobody has heard of the
internet very very few people and I came
across the fact that the web World Wide
Web was growing at something like
twenty-three hundred percent a year this
is an i-94 and anything growing that
fast is even if it's baseline usage
today is tiny it's growing so fast it's
gonna be big and so I looked at that and
I was like there's got to be I should
come up with a business idea then they
get you know on the internet and then
let the internet go around this and we
can keep working on it and so I made a
list of products that I might saw my and
I started forced ranking them and I
picked books because books is super
unusual in one respect which is that
there are more book items in the book
category than there are items in the
other category the three million
different books active and in print
around the world in a given time so my
my the founding idea of Amazon was to
build Universal selection of books the
biggest bookstores only had 150,000
titles and so that's what I did and I
you know I hired a small team and we
built we built the software I moved to
Seattle and when you told your parents
you're gonna equip de sha where you're
successful making presumably a fair
amount of money yeah and you told your
wife McKenzie that you're gonna move
across the country what did they all say
they were immediately and reflexively
supportive right after they asked the
question what's the internet room number
42 delight the customers we haven't had
any existential crises knock on wood
if I don't want to jinx anything but
we've had a lot of kind of dramatic
events I remember there early on we only
had a hundred and 25 employees when
Barnes and Noble who the big you at
United States bookseller opened their
online website to compete against us
Barnes and noble.com we'd had about a
two year window we opened in 95 they
opened in 97 and at that time all of the
headlines and the funniest were about
how we were about to be destroyed by
this much larger company we had 125
employees and 60 million dollars a year
in annual sales
60 million with an M and that and Barnes
and Noble at the time had 30,000
employees and about three billion
dollars in sales so if they were giant
we were tiny and we had limited
resources and the the headlines were
very negative about Amazon and the one
that's most minimal our memorable was
just Amazon tossed and and so I called
it All Hands meeting which was not hard
to do with just 125 people we got in a
room and because it was so scary for all
of us this idea that now we finally had
a big competitor that literally
everybody's parents were calling and
saying you know are you ok is if it's
usually the mom's calling and asking
their children are you gonna be ok so
and I said look you know it it's ok to
be afraid but don't be afraid of our
competitors because they're never gonna
send us any money be afraid of our
customers and if we just stay focused on
them and instead of obsessing over this
big competitor that we just got that
will be fine and I really do believe
that I think that if you stay focused
then the more drama there is and
everything else no matter what the drama
is whatever the external distraction is
the what's your response to it should be
to double down on the customer
satisfying they're not just satisfying
they're delighting them rule number 43
follow your calling you don't choose
your passions your passions choose you
and all of us are gifted with certain
passions and the people who are lucky
are the ones who get to follow those
things and the i/os advise our young
employees or meet with interns as well
and you can have and my kids too you can
have a job or you can have a career or
you can have a calling and if you can
somehow figure out how to have a calling
you have hit the jackpot
because that's the big deal rule number
44 grow your vision what propel you to
sell things more than books after books
we surged slam music and then we started
selling videos and then I got smart and
I I emailed a thousand randomly selected
customers and asked them besides the
things we felt today what would you like
to see a cell and that answer came back
incredibly long-tailed the way they
answered the question was with whatever
they were looking for at that moment so
like ever one of the answers was I wish
you've sold windshield wiper blades
because I really need windshield wiper
blades and I thought to myself we can
sell anything this way and and then so
then we launched electronics and toys
and many other categories over time and
the vision became because you read the
original business plan it's just books
rule number 45 have good role models we
all get gifts and we get certain things
our life that are that we're very lucky
about and one of the most powerful one
is who your early role models are you
know you could think it was your
grandfather it was in a big sense my mom
and dad but my grandfather too and you
know I had my mom had me when she was 17
years old and she was still in high
school in Albuquerque New Mexico and
this is in 1964 I can assure you that
being a pregnant teenager in high school
was not cool in Albuquerque New Mexico
at that time and so it's in so it was a
very it was difficult for her my
grandfather went to bat for her they
tried to kick her out of school and you
know he there
incredible I had so the gift I had is I
had this incredible family rule number
46 maintain a day one culture now that
you have about 600,000 employees I
calculated you're adding about 250
people a day you've mentioned that
you're trying to fend off de - yeah and
you've said that day two is stasis
followed by irrelevance followed by
excruciating ly painful decline followed
by death yeah that's why it is always
day one yeah yeah how's that work well
so day one and this is a phrase that we
use at Amazon all the time I've been
using its in my first annual shareholder
letter from 20 years ago and we stay
it's always day one and it needs to be
day one for the reason that you just
mentioned and how do you so the real
question for me is how do you go about
maintaining a day one culture you know
it's great to have the scale of Amazon
we have financial resources we have lots
of brilliant people we can accomplish
great things we have global scope we
have operations all over the world but
the downside of that is that you can
lose your nimbleness you can lose your
entrepreneurial spirit you can lose your
that kind of heart that that small
companies often have and so if you could
have the best of both worlds
if you can have that entrepreneurial
spirit and heart while at the same time
having all the advantages that come with
scale and scope I think think of the
things that you could do and and so pop
the question is how do you achieve that
the scale is good because it makes you
robust you know a big box or can take a
punch to the head the question is you
also want to dodge those punches so
you'd like to be nimble you want to be
big and nimble and I find there are a
lot of things that are protective of the
day one mentality I already spent some
time on one of them which is customer
obsession I think that's the most
important thing if you can and it gets
harder as you get bigger when you're a
little tiny company so you're a 10
person startup company every single
person the company is focused on the
customer when you get to be a bigger
company you've got all the middle you've
got middle
managers and you've got all these layers
and the those people aren't on the
frontlines they're not interacting with
customers every day they're insulated
from customers and they start to manage
not the customer happiness directly but
they start to manage through proxies
like metrics and processes and some of
those things can become bureaucratic so
it's very challenging but one of the
things that happens is the
decision-making velocity slows down and
I think the reason one of the reasons
that that happens is that people also
junior executives inside the big company
start to model all decisions as if they
are heavyweight irreversible highly
consequential decisions and so even
two-way doors you could make you make a
decision it's the wrong decision you can
just back up back through the door and
try again
even those reversible decisions start to
be made with heavyweight processes and
so you can teach people that these
pitfalls and and and traps and then
teach them to avoid those traps and
that's what we're trying to do at Amazon
so that we can maintain our
inventiveness and our hearts and our
kind of small companies spirit even as
we have the scale and scope of a larger
company we number 47 be a good leader
I'm actually a big fan of anecdotes in
business not building a narrative
structure around them necessarily but I
still have an email address that
customers can write to I see most of
those emails and I don't answer very
many of them anymore but but I see them
and I and I forward them some of them
the ones that catch my curiosity I
forward them to the executives in
charges that area but with a question
mark and that question mark is just a
shorthand for can you look into this why
is this happening what does what's going
on and what I find is strange because we
have tons of metrics we have you know
weekly business reviews with these
metric decks and we look at our we know
so many things about customers
and they're there you know whether we're
delivering on time what you know whether
the packages have too much air in them
and you know wasteful of packaging and
so we have so many metrics that we
monitor and the thing I have noticed is
that when the anecdotes and the data
disagree the anecdotes are usually right
there's something wrong with the way
you're measuring it and that's why it's
so important to to keep your you need
the to run it's something that you were
you're doing you know shipping billions
of packages a year for sure you need
good data and metrics and are you
delivering on time you deliver on time
in every city are you delivering on time
to apartment complexes are you
delivering on time in certain countries
you do need the data but then you need
to check that data with your intuition
and your instincts and you need to teach
that to the all the senior executives
and and junior executives to rule number
48 never be satisfied the great thing
about humans in general is we're always
improving things and so entrepreneurs
and inventors and you know if they
follow their curiosity and they follow
their passions and they figure something
out and then they figure out how to make
it better and they're never satisfied
and and you need to harness that in my
view you need to harness that energy
primarily on your customers instead of
on your competitors and so where I see I
sometimes see companies and even young
small start-up companies entrepreneurs
go awry is they start to pay more
attention to their competition than they
do to their customers and I think that
that I think that in big mature
industries that can be that might be a
winning approach in some cases kind of
close following let other people be the
pioneers and you know and go down the
blind alleys there's many things that a
new inventive company tries won't work
and so those mistakes and errors and
failures do cost real money and and and
so maybe in a mature industry that we're
growth rates are slow and change is very
slow but as
see in the world more and more there
aren't very many mature industries
change is happening everywhere you know
we see it in the automobile industry
with self-driving cars and but you could
go right down the line of every industry
and you would see it
rule number 49 make it happen what was
your moment you thought I might not make
it the riskiest moment for Amazon
charlie was at the very very beginning I
needed to raise a million dollars at a
certain point and I ended up giving away
20% of the company for a million dollar
hell of a deal for somebody a lot of
people did very well in that deal but
they but they also took a risk so they
deserve to do very well on that deal but
I I had to take 60 meetings to raise a
million dollars and I raised it from 22
people at approximately fifty thousand
dollars a person and it was nip and tuck
whether I was could go raise that money
so the whole thing could have ended
before he even started that was 1995 you
know and the first question every
investor asked me was what's the
internet and rule number 50 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
laughs I loved high school I had so much
fun we had I lost my library privileges
because I laughed too loudly in the
library and that laughs where did you
get that laughter um you know it is
distinctive I've had that laugh all my
life there was a short not that short
there was a multi-year period where my
brother and sister would not see a movie
with me because they thought it was too
embarrassing
and my but I don't know why I have this
laugh it's just it's just and I laugh
easily and often the people who know me
you know yes my mom or anybody who knows
me well and they'll say if Jeff's
unhappy wait five minutes now I have a
special bonus gift from Jeff on how to
be focused that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what is your intuition telling you to do
number two what does choosing a life of
adventure
sure mean to you and number three who
are to role models that you're going to
study and learn from and if you liked
this video and you're gonna take
immediate action give me a hashtag
belive down in the comments as well
I've always been focused when I was in
Montessori School the Montessori School
teacher told my mom that I wouldn't
switch tasks and they were and they got
me to switch tasks by picking me up
including my chair and just moving me to
the new task station I've gotten a
little better about that over the years
but it's still task switching is still a
problem for me if you want to learn more
about Jeff and Amazon's journey check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there the web
usage in the spring of 1994 was growing
at 2,300 percent a year you know things
just don't grow that fast it's highly
unusual